[Music]
hello I'm Justin Kirkland product
manager at Google and I'm joined here by
my colleague Sebastian NGO has gained at
Phenom II where he leads kubernetes
sebastian can you tell me a little bit
about what you're hearing from users and
customers about kubernetes in bit Nami
sphere sure so you know me as you said I
I lead all the community's efforts
open-source so we work on application
packaging specifically for communities
so of course containers but then we
package and we deliver on kubernetes you
know gke of course is one of the the
target platforms and you know people
it's still a little bit early you know I
mean the conference is booming 4,000
people but it's still early in Indo
space where you know users are migrating
to micro services and cloud native
applications so they need a lot of help
in first understanding the the entire
space and then understanding how their
application is going to look like in
communities on that platform so we help
them do that and then we help them
package those apps you know make the
good choices in terms of container izing
them using things like helm charts or
maybe a get-ups like pipeline to to
deploy so you've really seen this this
shift in development methodologies from
the developers perspective yeah and you
know personally I like to think of it
also as it's more of a general shift
with DevOps and you know being able to
be extremely quick to market to react
extremely quickly you know compared to a
more traditional type of application
development where you know that's slower
and and people you know need a you know
months or years to to deploy apps here
we see people realizing that they need
to go extremely quickly so that's where
micro services containers and then a
platform like like cube you know makes
it extremely easy was rolling updates
see ICD of course see ICD of course you
which is integrated but interestingly I
mean we have to be realistic a lot of
people are still not there so you know
yes see ICD but we need to help those
people who are maybe not you know
quite there yet with their pipeline with
their software development pipeline you
know get them on board with this new new
way
of doing doing apps right and where do
you see the challenges are right now
where are people stopping their toes
well so you need to you know you need to
help them understand the impact of those
technologies I always say you know
adopting a tech just because that's the
new thing you know going creepin it is
just because capabilities is really hot
right now that's not the good reason so
they really need to understand that you
know they need a software factory they
need their developers on board with you
know using a version control of course
but then automatically building
containers understanding the manifest
for communities so it's an entire you
know lifecycle of software a life cycle
of the application that they need to
embrace and you know you we need to
start at the beginning which is you know
the devs of course and then you know we
need to approach the operators because
it's a big change for the the operators
of the infrastructure they need to be on
board with adopting the communities API
to manage this infrastructure you know
so it's an entire effort there of
transformation for collaborative right
so you're you're quite involved in the
community and you've you've certainly
seen and met a lot of people around
kubernetes over the years so were some
of the people that inspire you maybe you
want to give a shout out to or give a
thanks to on on camera here yeah I was I
started in Cuban eighties you know 2014
when I wrote the docker cookbook so I
met Joe Beda remotely and he helped me
write some of the the communities
content before you went GA so and I can
say that I was there early but I don't
work on core I really work on the edge
because I you know I created a startup
which was acquired by a by bitna me so
I'm really on the edge not really
contributing to to core per se but the
people are really admiring I mean Joe
Beda is you know one of them extremely
smart of course which was at Google
before and worked on on GCE and and then
I have to say that Brian grant is quite
impressive to me as a you know smooth
guy you know quiet but extremely sharp
and when when you point out a technical
problem it brings up like a github issue
or a PR with this with its number so
it's quite quite impressive well thank
you Sebastian
appreciate your time yeah Cheers
you